la de docteur honoris causa au docteur
denis mukwege du nobel de la paix le
docteur congolais denis mukwege gay est
honoré par l'université de montréal
l'homme qui répare les femmes a consacré
sa vie à lutter contre les violences
sexuelles qui ronge son pays
la violence sexuelle ce n'est pas une
question des femmes ce n'est pas une
question de féministes c'est une
question des humanistes
malgré le sous financement chronique et
le manque de personnel le docteur a
soigné plus de 96 mille femmes dont la
moitié avait le corps brisé par les
viols collectifs utilisé comme arme de
guerre
mais voilà qu'une entente avec
l'université de montréal pourrait
faciliter le travail du médecin auteur
auquel j'ai fait un travail absolument
essentiel fondamental remarquable à
l'hôpital panzi l'université s'allie à
la fondation de son hôpital en
république démocratique du congo
il ya d'abord une contribution en nature
qui est extrêmement importante
il ya des experts de plusieurs facultés
qui vont être mis à contribution on
monte un dossier d'une chair fine
anthropique et on voit je vais me
promener pour aller essayer d'avoir des
donateurs pour le moment aucun montant
ni échéancier n'est associé à l'entente
maintenant si on a l'appui de
l'université on a une collaboration
officielle avec panzi ça va faciliter
les choses
on va avoir la possibilité d'aller plus
rapidement réaliser des choses plus
concrètement que ce qu'on pouvait faire
jusque là
on n'apprend pas comme consommer galles
en attendant de trouver les réponses
le docteur denis mukwege veux obtenir
justice
on ne peut pas construire la paix sans
et aujourd'hui je crois que l'impunité
totale en république démocratique du
congo dans une enquête
l'onu avait dressé l'inventaire de 617
violations des droits de l'homme commis
sur le territoire de la rdc entre mars
1993 et juin 2003 des crimes qui pour la
plupart sont restés impunis et dont les
séquelles sont encore vives
tu apprends le français ici marie josée
paquet comme radio canada montréal